so let's talk about the four color
theorem it's a favorite with
mathematicians it's easy to state so the
statement is every map can be colored
using four colors such that two
neighboring countries are different
colors that would be confusing if it
wasn't so all maps can be done in four
colors in other words I'm saying there
are no maps that need five colors it's
not obvious and you'd think more
complicated maps would need more colors
but apparently all maps can be done with
just four colors or better so this
problem
wells unsolved for a long time 125 years
it was unsold it was solved finally in
the 1970s although the method they used
to solve it was a little controversial
at the time but has had a large effect
on mathematics today so the story of how
this problem came around is kind of
keeps apparently there was a guy who was
trying to color in the counties of
Britain I don't know why he was trying
to do that but he was and he suspected
he could do it using four colors and he
mentioned it to his brother and his
brother was a math student and his
brother mentioned it to his lecturer who
was a man called or Gustus de Morgan
he's a famous mathematician and when it
was de Morgan who spread this problem
around so to prove it we either need to
show that every map can be done with
four colors or better or we just need to
find one example that needs five colors
so people were trying it and if you try
it with maps it does work if you try it
with the map of the world you can color
it with four colors if you try it with
the map of the United States you can do
it with four colors you try any real map
you can do it with four colors I mean
you can get this problem two children
right if you want to keep them quiet
after a while you start to think well
maybe I'll need to invent a map maybe if
I can invent a weird complicated map I
can find one that needs five colors so
that's what you start to do doesn't look
like any sort of real-life map so we got
this map and now we're going to color of
it so let's start with the
I think orange next country has to be a
different color so I'm using the purple
here let's try the next country so this
is all fairly simple I can't use purple
I can't use orange because they're
touching I'll use the blue next one what
do you want what do you want lady well
we can't use blue or orange we could use
purple again ah why that is a wise
choice let's use purple again why not
let's not go to the expense of using a
fourth color so now let's do this one
blue again and we can use perdu again so
that one excellent that might put us in
a good position maybe to the next
country so here we've got we can't use
blue we can't use purple what should we
use we can use orange why not and I join
you use the orange on the opposite one
so we'll do this one in orange and then
we need a fourth color we do need you
have to go to the fourth color do we
yeah yeah yep purple blue and orange are
being used this does have to go into the
fourth color I've got pink here on the
opposite side it's the same obviously
all these pink over here it looks like
we have to use four colors for that so
okay so this is a map that was solvable
with four colors here's another
important map I'll make you like that
there's only four countries but if we
try and color it in and I'll do
something similar I'll do the orange in
the middle again purple up here well
this one can't be purple it can't be our
angel means blue and this country it
can't be orange it can't be purple it
can't be blue so I'm forced to use the
fourth color which is the pink so this
is an example of a map that definitely
needs four colors so we're going to boil
the problem down a little bit they say I
took this map again I'll draw it here
say map instead of coloring it in all
the sections let's just say I color in
at the center of each region I will just
get the same idea won't it I don't have
to use all that in and maybe instead of
drawing out the whole map maybe if I
just said if two countries are touching
each other they share a border right
I'll just connect them with a line what
I've made is I turn that
app into a network so this map has made
this network and the question can this
map be colored using four colors or
better is the same question of saying
can this network be colored using four
colors or better such that two countries
that are connected with a line are not
the same color so it kind of boils down
the problem it makes it more abstract
but that's actually a good thing
it makes it easier to solve there are
things we can learn now about maps by
studying networks instead so the reason
we want to use networks for a start it
shows when two maps are the same I'll
show you I mean what about if I had a
map that looks like this yeah so this
this map looks like a handbag as
Radiesse this told me but if we draw the
network for this map so I'm just going
to put the adat in each region and then
I'll connect them if they're connected
like this you will find that you get the
same network as this previous map we did
so there's four countries again it gives
me the same network is effectively the
same map even though it looks different
so by studying networks we can study all
the different kinds of maps even when
they look different now all maps make
networks but not all network are valid
maps I'll show you what I mean this is
not going to be a valid map and I'm
going to say we're all going to be
touching each other nor mutually
touching countries we all share borders
so it looks like I got this right looks
like that now this is not going to be a
valid map because if you try and turn
that into a map it's not going to work
the problem is the lines cross which
when you try and turn it into a map
doesn't make sense you can try but it
just doesn't make sense it is allowed if
we can untangle the lines and that might
happen I'll show you what I mean so so
these are countries here and let's say
these countries touch each other as well
so I would connect them with a line but
if I do that you see the lines cross I
don't have to do it that way I could
have drawn a line like that so I could
have
entangled that so if I can untangle it
that's fine that's a valid map and my
study networks there are some features
of maps that we can learn by looking at
networks this one in particular in any
map you're going to have a country let's
call it a country a right there's going
to be a country in every map those
either just by itself or on like an
island or country a is connected to one
other country I mean that might happen
or country a is connected to two other
countries so you'll get a network that
looks like that that'll be country a
there in the middle or you might have
country a which is character three
countries this all seems perfectly
reasonable as a in the center country a
could be connected to four countries or
now for a in or country a could be
connected to five countries and that all
seems reasonable but every map will have
at least one country that looks like one
of these what you can't have is every
country connected to six other countries
or more all I'm saying is there is at
least one country in that map that's
either connected to one or two or three
or four or five but if you have a map
where they're all mutually connected to
six or more countries that's a network
that can't be untangled
so all maps have this feature one of the
countries is one of these on this list
now we can start talking about the four
color theorem this is actually really
useful so the full color theorem is hard
to prove and they tried for a long time
like I said it took 125 years they did
manage to prove easier versions of the
four color theorem so the four color
theorem means there are no maps that
need five colors I can probably prove
that there are no maps that need seven
colors that's probably easier to explain
okay I'm going to have a go okay imagine
there are maps that need seven colors
these are maps that can't be done with
better right so there are maps that
seven pick the floor each one okay so
you've got a small one now because it's
a map it's going to contain a country
which is going to be one of these A's
that I've called here on this list so
take that country and put it out to
delete it take it away you've made a
smaller map now because it's a smaller
map that means you can do it in six
colors do you remember the map I had was
the smallest that had to use seven so if
I take a country away smaller I can do
it with six great if I put my country a
back in that means I have a spare color
to use for a I mean the worst-case
scenario is this last one here and these
could be all different colors they might
put a back in I'm still going to have a
spare color a six color that I can use
which shows that the map can be done in
six colors after all now the shown that
all maps can be done with five colors
that's a little bit harder
the proof is exactly the same the proof
is exactly the same except in this
worst-case scenario down here at the end
here and it becomes harder because if
those are five different colors and you
put your country a back in you might
have to reuse a color which you don't
want to do so the arguments a bit more
complicated you have to show that you
can recolor it and you still have a
spare color for a so it's a harder proof
but it's along the same line then they
try to do it with four can we share that
all maps can be done with four colors
and that argument doesn't quite work it
just wasn't strong enough so this went
unsolved for a long time so where some
people who thought they'd proved it they
thought they'd actually done it and
people accepted the proof and they
thought it was sold in four decade we
thought oh it's done and then they found
a mistaken when actually that doesn't
hold up and then I'll know it wasn't
proved we have to go back to square one
we have to find a way to prove this
problem so it took till the 1970s to
solve this problem so the final solution
it was done by two guys Kenneth Apple
and Wolfgang Haken from the University
of Illinois
19:56 is kind of similar to my proof I
mentioned before they made a list of
networks and he said every map must have
at least one of these networks within it
and they showed that every map contains
one of these networks each one of those
networks can be colored with four colors
or can be recolored with four colors and
that that is enough to show that every
map can be done with four colors now it
is a hard proof and a part of the
problem was having to show that this
list could be colored with four colors
because it was a long list there were
how many networks was on this list 1938
networks and to do that they use the
computer and that was controversial at
the time this was the first computer
assisted proof in mathematics
now it's commonplace lots of mathematics
is done with computers but this was the
first and people were wary of this proof
for a start one of the problems is
involves checking lots of cases that's
not the best kind of proof it is a
proven is valid but the problem with
that is it doesn't give you a deeper
understanding of why something is true
just checking lots of cases
mathematicians not do not necessarily
like that kind of truth it's not the
best kind but it's still a valid proof
the proof has been improved for a start
we had this long list of networks that
we had to show we could color in that
got shortened think it got shortened to
some like one thousand four hundred and
something I think it's shorter now I'm
not sure how short it is at the moment
at the moment though the proof still
requires this massive checking of cases
so it's still not a beautiful proof this
episode has been brought to you by
Squarespace get 10% off your first order
with them by going to Squarespace comm
slash numberphile now I use Squarespace
pretty much every day to maintain all
sorts of things from my blog online
store and all sorts of
website it's a great all-in-one setup
for everything right from buying your
domain name at the start through to
designing the page itself I've got all
these award-winning templates they're
really good but you can tweak them as
you see fit of course and importantly
these sites look equally good on
computers or mobile devices it's all
taken care of for you so whatever your
next move is online
Squarespace is going to make it so much
easier and also look much more
professional give them a look it really
doesn't matter what you're doing these
days whether it's just sort of a CV type
site or some kind of shop you really
need a class the online presence and
that's what you're going to get here go
to squarespace.com slash numberphile and
check them out you can even do a free
trial before committing and remember to
use numberphile to get 10% off your
first purchase
Squarespace comm slash numberphile or
you can use the code numberphile thanks
to them for supporting this video